ja meine damen und herren und wir wollen
natürlich schnell in den plenarsaal
schauen denn die debatte zum
infektionsschutzgesetz zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wird jetzt
natürlich gleich aufgerufen und wir
schauen mal in den saal die
bundeskanzlerin habe ich gesehen wie hat
den plenarsaal bereits betreten in der
tat und angela merkel wird in dieser
debatte dann auch das wort ergreifen
es ist ja ja knapp drei wochen her da
war die bundeskanzlerin in der talkshow
anne will und hat laut darüber nach
gesicht zu angesichts der korona
maßnahmen und das will was der länder ob
der bund nicht besser einheitlich bei
der pandemie bekämpfung durchgreifen
sollte und heute sehen wir ein resultat
aus die lesung des gesetzentwurfs ist
jetzt hören wir den
bundestagspräsidenten wolfgang schäuble
dankeschön die sie ziemlich eröffnet der
ältestenrat ist gestern einvernehmlich
übereingekommen dass die präsenzpflicht
am dienstag der nächsten sitzungswoche
aufgehoben wird
nach paragraf 14 absatz 1 satz 2 des
abgeordnetengesetzes beschrieben ich
deshalb dass der dienstag zwanzigster
april 21 nicht als sitzungstag gilt
damit dem feld unter anderem die pflicht
sich an diesem tag in die
anwesenheitslisten einzutragen
und jetzt wo ich auf die zusatzpunkte 6
und 7 beratung des von den fraktionen
der cdu/csu und spd eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zum schutz der
bevölkerung bei einer epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite sowie beratung
des antrags der fraktion die linke mit
dem titel mehr sicherheit und
lebensqualität mit schnelltests und
selbst fest für alle
für die aussprache eine dauer von 60
minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und datei das
wort der bundeskanzlerin merkel
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren die
letzte beratung von bund und ländern zur
pandemie bekämpfung am 22 märz habe ich
und das habe ich ja auch öffentlich
gesagt als zäsur empfunden und ich weiß
dass es nicht nur mir so gegangen ist
sondern vielen von uns zugleich wissen
wir es führt kein weg daran vorbei wir
müssen die dritte welle der pandemie
brennen und den rapiden anstieg der
infektionen stoppen um das endlich zu
schaffen müssen wir die kräfte von bund
ländern und kommunen besser bündeln als
zuletzt und deshalb ziehen wir jetzt die
im wortsinne notwendigen konsequenzen
aus der zensur des 22 märz am dienstag
hat die bundesregierung dazu den entwurf
eines vierten gesetzes zum schutz der
bevölkerung bei einer epidemischen lage
von nationaler tragweite im kabinett
beschlossen und heute beraten die ihn in
erster lesung in diesem hause diese
ergänzung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
heißt auf den wichtigsten nenner
gebracht wir setzen die notbremse
bundesweiten die bundeseinheitlich
geltenden notbremse ist nach meiner
überzeugung dringend sie ist überfällig
denn ich muss es auch heute leider
wieder sagen die lage ist ernst und zwar
sehr ernst und wir alle müssen sie auch
ernst nehmen
die dritte welle der pandemie hat unser
land fest im griff
das sagen die täglichen infektionszahlen
des robert koch instituts das sagt die
entwicklung des erwerbs und das sagen
vor allem die zahlen der belegten
intensivbetten gerade auch in dieser
woche die intensivmediziner senden einen
hilferuf nach dem
anderen wer sind wir denn wenn wir diese
notrufe über hören wird die wird belegen
und kollegen das dürfen wir nicht wir
dürfen ärzte und pfleger nicht alleine
lassen
alleine können sie den kampf gegen das
virus in dieser dritten welle auch mit
bester medizinischer kunst und dem
aufopferungsvollen einsatz nicht
gewinnen
sie brauchen unsere unterstützung sie
brauchen die unterstützung von staat
politik gesellschaft ärzte und pfleger
brauchen die unterstützung von uns
bürgerinnen und bürgern von uns allen
und deshalb müssen wir unsererseits
alles tun um die dritte welle zu bremsen
um sie zu brechen und sie umzukehren und
deshalb müssen wir die pandemie
bekämpfung von bund und ländern mit der
bundesgesetzlichen ergänzung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes auf neue füße
stellen
genau das ist die bundeseinheitliche
notbremse über die wir heute beraten wo
die inzidenz über 100 liegt sollen
künftig bundeseinheitliche regelungen
gelten die notbremse ist da nicht mehr
auslegungssache sondern sie greift
automatisch und neben der schon im
arbeitsschutzrecht vereinbarten pflicht
zum home office wo immer das möglich ist
und der pflicht von arbeitgebern in
zukunft auch nächster woche test
mindestens einmal in der woche zum teil
auch zweimal in der woche für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
anzubieten
wenn ich mir sehr wohl bewusst dass hier
in diesem gesetz hat einschränkungen
vereinbart werden für alle kreise in
denen die incidents oberhalb von 100
liegt
kontakt beschränkung schließung von
geschäften kultur und sporteinrichtungen
richtungen nächtliche
ausgangsbedingungen und gerade über die
ausgangs beschränkungen gibt es ja eine
intensive diskussion das für und wider
sowohl hinsichtlich der mit ihr
verbundenen freiheitseinschränkung als
auch nicht zuletzt darüber ob sie
überhaupt etwas bringt diese einwände
nehme ich ernst und ich setze mich
natürlich auch mit ihnen auseinander und
möchte das auch hier tun zunächst
ausgangs beschränkungen sind keine neue
erfindung sondern im aktuell geltenden
infektionsschutz ausgangs beschränkungen
und das ganze dafür eine allgemeine
bemerkungen biel ohne liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen was immer wir für eine
meinung die meisten haben glauben sie
angesichts der notlage und sorgen
unserer mitbürger und mitläufer dass wir
dem nicht auch in der art über das hier
debattieren rechnung tragen müssten die
kritiker herzlich
ausgangs beschränkungen sind keine neue
erfindung sondern im aktuell geltenden
infektionsschutzgesetz als maßnahme
bereits angelegt und in mehreren
bundesländern bereits seit monaten
angewandt auch eine vielzahl anderer
staaten großbritannien irland frankreich
die niederlande portugal hat ausgangs
beschränkungen praktiziert oder
praktiziert sie noch warum machen diese
länder das zum teil im übrigen erheblich
restriktiver als wir das überlegen und
warum steht diese maßnahme auch heute in
unserem gesetzentwurf weil es in der
pandemie bekämpfung stets um die
reduzierung von kontaktmöglichkeiten
gehen muss muss es immer auch um die
reduzierung von mobilität gehen
ich höre sehr wohl wenn manche aerosol
forscher darauf hinweisen dass man sich
im freien sehr viel weniger an steckt
als in geschlossenen räumen aber bei der
ausgangs beschränken geht es ja um etwas
anderes
es geht darum abendliche besuchs
bewegungen von einem ort zum anderen im
übrigen auch unter benutzung des
öffentlichen nahverkehrs zu reduzieren
das heißt also für mich ausgangs
beschränkungen sind natürlich kein
allheilmittel gegen die ausbreitung des
virus sie können ihre wirkung in der
kombination mit anderen maßnahmen
entfalten zum beispiel auch mit strengen
kontakt beschränken und so müssen wir
dann entscheiden ob der mit der ausgangs
begrenzung verbundene effekt die
nachteile natürlich den nicht zu
leugnenden erheblichen eingriff in die
persönliche freiheit recht werden
rechtfertigen kann
ob sie also unter abwägung des für und
wider eine geeignete verhältnismäßige
und erforderliche maßnahmen sind und ich
komme zu dem ergebnis dass die vorteile
dieser maßnahme im zusammenhang mit der
bekämpfung der pandemie die nachteile
über
gegen und deshalb möchte ich auch für
diese maßnahme in der form wie wir sie
im gesetz vorgeschlagen haben werden wie
ich auch wie ich auch für weitere
maßnahmen des gesetzentwurfs werben
möchte obwohl sie gegenwärtig natürlich
im parlamentarischen verfahren alle heiß
diskutiert werden schulen und kitas
spätestens ab einer inzidenz von 200
schließen ja oder nein
home office noch stärker durchsetzen ja
oder nein
verpflichtendes testangebot von
arbeitgebern ja oder nein
click and meet in geschäften ja oder
nein liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich kenne die diskussion sehr wohl und
ich habe menschlich auch jedes
verständnis für den impuls hier eine
erleichterung zu suchen dort maßnahmen
etwas weniger streng zu gestalten
beziehungsweise wenn ich es bewusst
etwas zugespitzt sagen darf hier ein
schlupfloch zu suchen und dort jenes
aber wenn das den betroffenen wirklich
helfen würde wäre ich sofort dabei
aber das tut es nicht im gegenteil denn
wir nach 13 monaten pandemie eine
lektion doch wirklich gelernt haben dann
ist dass diese das virus verzeiht keine
halbherzigkeiten sie machen alles nur
noch schwerer
das währungspaar zeit kein zögern
es dauert alles nur noch länger das
virus lässt sich nicht mit nicht mit
sich verhandeln
es war steht nur eine einzige sprache
die sprache der entschlossenheit
entschlossenheit jetzt hilft am ende
allen so viel mehr davon bin ich
überzeugt als wenn wir jetzt wieder
zögern und halbherzig vorging
alle maßnahmen haben ein einziges ziel
unser ganzes land aus dieser furchtbaren
phase der stetig steigenden
infektionszahlen der sich füllenden
intensivstationen der bestürzten ton
täglichen zahl der korona toten
herauszuführen und zwar zum wohle aller
und er als wenn wir uns weiter durch
diese zeit irgendwie durch den
durchschnitten wir haben es doch schon
einmal geschafft wir können es auch
jetzt wieder schaffen und haben jetzt
anders als im letzten jahr
auch die impfkampagne die uns ja enorm
hilft seit die hautärzte mitmachen auch
die betriebsärzte werden noch
hinzukommen geht es richtig voran
die notbremse ist also das instrument
die drohende überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern
systematisches testen ist das mittel bei
niedrigeren instanzen kontrollierte und
nachhaltige öffnungen zu ermöglichen und
das impfen ist der schlüssel
die pandemie zu überwinden liebe
kolleginnen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ich kann diese rede nicht schließen ohne
auch heute wieder den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zu danken wir politiker machen
ist ihnen wirklich nicht immer leicht
aber diese übergroße mehrheit der bürger
macht und hilft unverändert mit ihre
geduld für ihre einsicht für ihre
fürsorge für andere und unser ganzes
land auch nach dieser langen langen zeit
immer noch danken möchte ich auch ihnen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
koalitionsfraktionen die auch der
oppositionsfraktion für ihre kritisch
konstruktive mitarbeit und für die
bereitschaft den gesetzentwurf im
bundestag und bundesrat zügig zu beraten
denn machen wir uns nichts vor jeder tag
zählt jeder tag früher an dem die
notbremse bundesweit angewandt ist ist
ein gewonnener tag dafür bitte ich sie
um unterstützung damit uns dieses
wichtige gesetze sehr bald
helfen kann die dritte welle zu brechen
herzlichen dank
ja wenn es nach der bundeskanzlerin und
der bundesregierung gegangen wäre dann
wäre dieses gesetz am besten schon in
dieser woche komplett durch
parlamentarische verfahren gegangen aber
die fdp fraktion unter anderem und auch
die afg fraktion die haben haben sich
gegen ein extremes eilverfahren
ausgesprochen obwohl das verfahren auch
jetzt noch sehr schnell sein sollte
gehören jetzt für die afg alice weil die
fraktionsvorsitzende
sehr geehrter herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
noch nie hat es eine bundesregierung
gewagt in so wenigen sätzen so viele
angriffe auf die grund und
freiheitsrechte der bürger auf
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratische
prinzipien unterzubringen wie in diesem
gesetzesentwurf die vorgeschlagene
ergänzung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
ist ein alarmierendes dokument
obrigkeitsstaatlichen denkens dieser
rückfall in den autoritären ungeist geht
vom kanzleramt aus und von ihnen frau
bundeskanzlerin ihr misstrauen gegenüber
den bürgern und den demokratischen und
rechtsstaatlichen institutionen hat bei
diesem gesetzesvorhaben eindeutig die
hand geführt
sie misstrauen den bürgern deswegen
wollen sie sie tagsüber gängeln und
nachts einsperren
sie misstrauen in ländern und kommunen
deswegen legen sie die axt an die
wurzeln der föderalen architektur der
bundesrepublik und machten
ministerpräsidenten landräte und
bürgermeister per bundesgesetz sie
misstrauen den gerichten den berufenen
kontrolleuren staatlichen handelns
deswegen stellen sie die amts und
verwaltungsgerichte durch
zentralisierung kalt möglicherweise weil
diese nämlich eben zuletzt einige ihrer
eingriffe in die bürgerrechte gekippt
haben und nun lassen sie sich eine
ermächtigung ihre wortwahl nicht
ins gesetz schreiben rechtsverordnung
mit zustimmung des bundesrats zu
erlassen
wir sagen dazu ausgangssperren sind
unverhältnismäßig und verfassungswidrig
für millionen von menschen die nicht zu
privilegiert bohnen wie zum beispiel
mitglieder des bundeskabinetts sind sie
die hölle im kampf gegen das virus in
ausgangssperren dagegen nutzlos ja sogar
kontraproduktiv
die infektionsgefahr ist nun mal im
freien fast null und hängt auch nicht
von uhrzeiten ab willkürlich
festgesetzte incident zahlen als
ausschlaggebendes kriterium sind
ebenfalls absurd sie hängen von der zahl
der durchgeführten tests ab und lassen
sich nach belieben hochtreiben ohne
rückkopplung an die test quote den
anteil tatsächlich erkranken und die
alterskohorten der betroffenen sind sie
auch nicht aussagekräftig das bestätigen
viele wissenschaftler zuletzt der
frühere chefideologe der charité
professor krüger hört auf die
wissenschaft so lautet ihr mantra sie
aber hören nur auf die stimmen die sie
hören wollen und die ihre vorurteile
bestätigen
widerspruch tun sie dagegen als
verschwörungstheorie acht dagegen
wäre doch eine differenzierte und
transparente debatte dringend nötig um
bessere entscheidungen treffen zu können
ging es ihnen tatsächlich in erster
linie um die pandemie bekämpfung hätten
sie längst geeignete und zielgerichtete
maßnahmen ergreifen können die auch wir
hier immer wieder eingefordert haben
cobit 19 ist vor allem für bestimmte
risikogruppen gefährlich dann muss man
auch diesen bedrohten personen gezielte
schutz angebote machen statt die
grundrechte für alle einzuschränken und
das ganze land an die wand zu fahren
die überlastung des gesundheitssystems
verhindert man weder mit zusperren der
gesellschaft noch mit
krankenhausschließungen und abbau von
intensivbetten sondern durch gezielte
investitionen in personal und
infrastruktur
dafür hatten sie genug zeit die nicht
genutzt wurde
sie wollen mit diesem gesetz etwas
anderes den endlosen bundes lockdown
obwohl fünf monate wellenbrecher
lockdown mehr als genug gezeigt haben
dass dieses primitive rezept überhaupt
nicht funktioniert und sie nehmen in
kauf dass der mittelstand zugrunde geht
der arbeitsmarkt durch staatliche dauer
intervention zerstört wird
dass innenstädte veröden eine ganze
schülergenerationen verloren geht und
das kultur und vereinsleben stirbt sie
belegen ganze branche mit berufsverboten
sieht eigenen händler und
gewerbetreibende gastronomen und
tourismusbetriebe durch monatelange
zwangsschließung ohne aussicht auf einen
ausweg zahllose geschäfte werden nie
mehr öffnen
generation alte familienbetriebe
verschwinden für immer in
unternehmerischen mittelstand bricht das
rückgrat auf deutschland
kommt eine insolvenzwelle von nie da
gewesenen dimension zu ein massiver
anstieg von depressionen geschädigten
kinderseelen in isolation verkümmern den
älteren menschen verstörten jugendlichen
und zerrütteten familien das sind die
kollateralschäden ihrer dauer lockdown
politik die bürger verlieren das
vertrauen in einen staat der einem vor
dem buch vor dem ruin stehende
westfälischen gastronomen ehepaar das
aus verzweiflung sein café wieder öffnet
das ordnungsamt und hohe bußgelder auf
den hals schickt die bürger verlieren
das vertrauen in einen staat der mit
polizeikommandos rentner geburtstages
stürmt und kinder vom bolzplatz jagd
aber drogenhändler im park gewähren
lässt die bürger verlieren das vertrauen
in einem staat dessen polizisten
erholungssuchende in parks mit
zollstöcken schikanieren aber bei klaren
groß hochzeiten untätig daneben stehen
müssen
seit mehr als einem jahr bis brauchen
sie die korona krise um zumutungen
durchzusetzen mit denen sie unter
normalen bedingungen niemals durchgehen
reise kontakt und versammlungsverbote
das einreißen der letzten haltelinien
bei der staatsverschuldung an die eu
schulden union die das budgetrecht des
parlaments aushebelt und die deutschen
steuerzahler in geiselhaft für brüsseler
ausgaben orgien und jetzt versuchen sie
am grundgesetz vorbei unter dem vorwand
des infektionsschutz es eine
notstandsgesetzgebung durch die
hintertüre einzuführen die von unserer
verfassung aus guten gründen nicht
vorgesehen ist nichts anderes bedeutet
es wenn sie bürger pauschal als
potenzielle gesundheitsgefährdung unter
generalverdacht stellen ihrer
grundrechte berauben und einsperren
worden es wäre grotesk
und falsch einer regierung die so oft
und offenkundig versagt und das recht
gebrochen hat derart weitreichende
zusätzliche kompetenzen zu geben ja fdp
fraktion lehnt deshalb aus tiefer
freiheitlicher und demokratischer
überzeugung diesem gesetzesentwurf
ich bedanke mich die
fraktionsvorsitzende der fw fraktion
alois seidl war das sehr und sie hat
nicht überraschend natürlich hier die
ablehnung bekräftigt und die hat das
auch gerade in ihrem wahlprogramm
festgeschrieben
am vergangenen wochenende die abkehr von
corona beschränkung dem mündigen bürger
sollen nach ansicht der a4 selbst
überlassen werden wie er sich vor der
pandemie schützen gehen der aussprache
hören wir jetzt als nächste rednerin für
die sozialdemokraten bärbel bas
[Applaus]
herr präsident frau bundeskanzlerin
meine damen und herren auch ich habe
keinen vorschlag gerade von frau weigel
und der fdp fraktion gehört wie sie wie
sie folgende situation bekämpfen will
und ich will das noch einmal
eindrücklich sagen die lage ist ernst
und meine fraktionen auch ich persönlich
sind nicht bereit die hilferufe aus den
krankenhäusern nicht zu hören
und deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
handeln und natürlich kann man das auch
als ländervertreter jetzt schon tun und
ich bin auch froh dass die ersten länder
auch sagen wir werden jetzt schon die
notbremse die seit längerem beschlossen
ist anwenden das ist der richtige und
wichtige schritt und dass wir das jetzt
in ein bundesgesetz ist hat natürlich
den hintergrund dass viele menschen von
uns erwarten dass es zur
bundeseinheitlichen maßnahmen kommt wie
oft haben wir darüber diskutiert dass es
einen flickenteppich gibt und die
infektionszahlen sind hoch und sie sind
deshalb hoch weil eben nicht alle diese
notbremse die möglich war angewandt
haben und sie auch nicht rechtzeitig
angewandt haben
das wollen wir jetzt mit diesem gesetz
mit dieser notbremse lösen und die
hilferufe der intensivmediziner aber
auch der pflegekräfte sind elementar für
diese entscheidung und jede infektion
und die zahlen steigen nach wie vor jede
infektion ist keine kleinigkeit
es ist keine kleinigkeit weil selbst die
die erkrankung lebend überstehen lange
damit zu kämpfen haben und deshalb
müssen wir die kontakte beschränken und
dazu gehören auch ausgangs
beschränkungen und die wissenschaft sagt
uns dass sie natürlich alleine
betrachtet nicht relevant sind aber im
paket mit vielen maßnahmen tests
pflichten da wo präsenz nicht dabei
präsenz möglich ist und auch nicht
umgangen werden kann braucht es die
masken verpflichten braucht es
verpflichtend und es braucht die kontakt
beschränkung da wo eben begegnung
prozent präsenz nicht bringt notwendig
ist das sind
entscheidenden schritte die wir jetzt
auch in dieses gesetz gießen und sie
sollten natürlich bei einer inzidenz von
über 100 einheitlich sein damit wir die
zahlen drücken damit wir die dritte
welle bekämpfen und danach können wir
auch über stufen pläne reden die liegen
ja auch in allen fraktionen vor und auch
das robert-koch-institut hat stufen
pläne entwickelt denn wir brauchen auch
eine eröffnungs perspektive und wenn wir
jetzt diese maßnahmen diese kontakt
beschränkungen ergreifen dann müssen wir
eben auch eine perspektive geben und
deutlich machen dass es gerade für
kinder und jugendliche auch ein aufruf
paket geben muss und da geht es nicht
nur um nachhilfe sondern es geht auch um
frühkindliche bildung psycho soziale
maßnahmen förderprojekte in den ferien
das sind die maßnahmen die dann auch
folgen müssen und dass wir die
hilfsprogramme ausbauen und ausweiten
das gehört für uns auch elementar dazu
und ausgangs beschränkungen gehören eben
auch dazu
und es ist wichtig dass wir diese
maßnahmen jetzt ergreifen weil es
einfach die notrufe gibt und ich will
das mal auch noch mal deutlich machen
damit die menschen auch verstehen warum
die note für so wichtig sind
es gibt ein beispiel der chef der kölner
universitätsklinik hat einfach mal
geschildert was gerade passiert das eben
zunehmend auch die jüngeren die wir im
moment noch nicht impfen können weil wir
nicht genug impfstoff haben jetzt auf
den intensivstationen landen und das hat
aber auch zur folge dass land auch zur
folge dass auf der anderen seite normale
erkrankung die auch einen intensiv platz
brauchen herzinfarkte unfälle die
passieren
abgelehnt werden müssen wichtige
operationen verschoben werden müssen wir
sind an einer situation ist es fünf nach
zwölf
und deshalb war
ist es wichtig dass wir diese maßnahmen
machen und das auch gemeinsam machen
natürlich kann man sich über das eine
oder andere jetzt im verfahren auch noch
unterhalten
das werden wir auch tun denn diese
notbremse muss richtig sein sie muss
wirken und sie muss auf auch
verfassungsgerichts sein und daran
arbeiten wir und der vorschlag ist dafür
geeignet und ich bitte sie deshalb
konstruktiv in die beratung zu gehen und
mitzuhelfen diese dritte welle zu
brechen herzlichen dank der basler ist
für die spd fraktion ja auch die spd
wird noch einige änderungen im
gesetzesverfahren an diesem
gesetzentwurf auch wenn er aussehen
reihen der koalitionsfraktionen kommt
erreichen wollen die fdp fraktion mit
schon im vorfeld harscher kritik an
diesem vorhaben hören jetzt in
fraktionsvorsitzende christian lindner
weit überwiegende teil dieses hauses
wird bei der beschreibung der lage
übereinstimmen sie ist ernst
das zeigen uns die infektionszahlen habe
mich gestern bei der leitung der charité
noch einmal unterrichten lassen darüber
welche entwicklungen auf den
intensivstationen zu beklagen ist
es hilft auch nichts dass wir uns in
deutschland vergleichen mit london wo es
in dieser woche eröffnungs schritt bei
der gastronomie und im handel gegeben
hat es macht auch keinen sinn zu
beklagen welche managementfehler es in
den vergangenen monaten seitens der
politik gegeben hat das hilft uns in
dieser situation jetzt nicht
es muss nun schnell wirksam und
rechtssicher gehandelt werden wirksame
maßnahmen sind die masken
eine wirksame maßnahme ist die
begrenzung der kontakte der haushalte
eine wirksame maßnahme ist eine test
strategie der fingerzeig auf die
wirtschaft ersetzt eine solche test
strategien indes nicht angesichts der
soziodemographie der schwererkrankten
empfiehlt sich eine gesundheitliche
aufklärung auch nicht nur in der
deutschen sprache und vereinen müssen
wir das tempo beim impfen erhöhen
durch den einsatz aller reserven durch
die zeitliche streckung zwischen erst
und zweitens und durch die einbeziehung
des gesamten niedergelassenen bereichs
schnelle wirksame und rechtssichere
maßnahmen stehen wir uns stehen uns zur
verfügung
der jetzige gesetzentwurf ist ja eine
reaktion auf das scheitern der
sogenannten oster uhr es ist richtig
dass nun bundeseinheitlich gehandelt
wird meine fraktion hat
bundeseinheitliche wenn dann regeln
bekanntlich im dezember vorgeschlagen
hier in diesem gesetzentwurf gibt es
allerdings nur eine nicht
differenzierter regel für das ganze
bundesgebiet
es ist im übrigen auch richtig den
deutschen bundestag zu beteiligen und
nicht ausschließlich nur auf die bund
länder runde der regierungschefin und
regierungschefs zu setzen
und trotzdem nimmt es wunder dass es nun
gar keine beteiligung der länder mehr
geben soll
es hätte sie ja geben können der
nordrhein westfälische ministerpräsident
hat sie ja sogar ein vorziehen der bund
länder runde vorgeschlagen
am montag wäre sie regulär gewesen und
nun gibt es keine ich glaube dass das
die falschen konsequenzen aus dem
scheitern der oster ruhe sind frau
bundeskanzlerin auch im verfahren im
kern dieser sogenannten bundes notbremse
das ging aus dem beitrag der
bundeskanzlerin und auch der kollegin
der spd hervor im kern steht nun die
ausgangs bremse ausgangssperre dieser
notbremse
in der praxis bedeutet das dass ein
geimpftes ehepaar aufgrund eines eines
ausbruchs kilometerweit entfernt in
einem einzelnen betrieb daran gehindert
wird alleine nach 21 uhr vor die tür zu
treten zum abendspaziergang um diesen
einen praktischen beispiel diesem
lebenssachverhalt drückt sich die ganzen
übrigen auch verfassungsrechtliche
problematik aus keine unterscheidung
zwischen geimpften und nicht geimpften
keine differenzierte bewertung
desinfektions geschehens cluster
ausbruch oder diffus keine anderen
parameter weshalb ja die praktikerinnen
und praktiker des landkreistages so
vehement gegen diese regelung
protestiert haben und im übrigen auch
die die sind immer gegen alles herr
brinkhaus das ist nun ein
misstrauensvotum gegenüber der
kommunalen ebene dass sie gerade zum
ausdruck gebracht haben und im übrigen
auch eine umstrittene wirksamkeit der
maßnahme der wissenschaftliche beirat
der französischen regierung hat die dort
ja über zwei monate ab 18 uhr
bestehenden ausgangssperren
wissenschaftlich evaluieren lassen mit
dem ergebnis dass sie eben keinen
beitrag zur begrenzung der infektionen
geleistet haben und aus diesem grund aus
diesem grund ist das was sie zur
ausgangssperre hier regeln wollen hoch
problematisch wir werden ihnen
vorschläge machen
dieses gesetz verfassungsfest zu machen
sollten sie diesen entschuldigen sie
bitte herr kollege brinkhaus in dieser
situation verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
an zu machen die wir das tun
das sollten sie eher schätzen denn sie
können kein interesse daran haben dass
dieses gesetz am ende weil sie auch
keinen hinweis eingehen in karlsruhe
scheitert der schaden für das vertrauen
in die pandemie politik insgesamt wäre
immens wenn sie verfassungsrechtliche
bedenken nicht ernst nehmen wir werden
es ist überhaupt nicht nur destruktiv
fabrik herr kollege brinkhaus herr
kollege brinkhaus die art und weise wie
sie hier argumentieren spricht
eigentlich für sich
und im übrigen im übrigen will ich sagen
will ich sagen dass wenn wenn sie auf
diese bedenken ja nicht nur von uns
vorgetragen werden nicht eingehen wir
uns gezwungen sehen
aus der fdp fraktion den weg nach
karlsruhe im wege von
verfassungsbeschwerden zu gehen
diese ausgangs beschränkung ist im
übrigen nicht nur verfassungsrechtlich
hochproblematisch
der kollege lauterbach hat gestern wie
ich glaube realistischerweise darauf
hingewiesen dass aufgrund der hunderter
inzidenz und der art und weise wie diese
notbremse nun automatisch ausgelöst
werden soll
an vielen stellen über viele wochen es
zu einer ausgangssperre kommen könnte
und da muss man unterscheiden zwischen
denjenigen die die in komfortablen grund
verhältnissen sind aber was ist denn mit
den studierenden im ein zimmer
appartement was ist denn mit der familie
wie ohne balken der etagenwohnung auf
engerem raum zusammenlebt die werden
dann möglicherweise wenn herr
lauterbachs prognose recht hat über
wochen in den räumen sein während es
draußen bereits hell ist und das ist ein
enormer sozialer schaden der damit
verbunden ist
im übrigen herr kollege bringen kauf
nehmen sie doch bitte zur kenntnis sie
haben jetzt ja gestrichen in ihrem
gesetzentwurf die möglichkeit des tests
basieren des basierten öffnen
der vorsitzende des teams vorsicht der
bayerische ministerpräsident
der hat am 9 april am siebten april mit
seinem landeskabinett noch beschlossen
dass zwischen der hunderter und 200h
incidents termin shopping mit test
möglich ist ab der 200er incidents ist
dort immer noch handel möglich nach dem
modell click and collect das sagt der
vorsitzende des teams vorsicht und
verehrte anwesende liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das könnte dafür sprechen
entweder ist es eine frage des
politischen charakters oder es könnte
dafür sprechen dass vom handel ohne
kontakt tatsächlich kein
infektionsrisiko ausgeht ich neige der
zweiten interpretation zu liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das debakel der
oster ruhe darf sich nicht wiederholen
und deshalb ist mein appell an die
regierungsfraktionen nehmen sie die aus
den ländern aus der rechtswissenschaft
von praktikern und auch aus dem
parlament vorgetragenen
verfassungsrechtlichen bedenken ernst
machen sie es sich bitte nicht so leicht
wie der kollege brinkhaus sagt christian
lindner der fraktionschef der fdp
fraktion und was die experten sagen
übrigens zu diesem gesetzentwurf das
wird sich heute nachmittag schon zeigen
denn da gibt es schon eine öffentliche
expertenanhörung zu dem gesetzentwurf
lauterbach ist von christian lindner ja
angesprochen worden
herr präsident meine kolleginnen und
kollegen zunächst einmal lindner
sie haben mich richtig zitiert aber
nicht vollständig zitiert und das ist in
diesem zusammenhang ist es bedeutsam ich
habe darauf hingewiesen und womit sie
recht haben dass wir in sehr vielen
landkreisen eine instanz von unter 100
nicht erreichen werden dann würde die
notbremse mit den ausgangs
beschränkungen gelten sowie von ihnen
vorgetragen
ich habe aber auch darauf hingewiesen
dass es nicht so sein muss weil wir
andere maßnahme greifen können und
müssen
und aus meiner sicht wäre es fair
gewesen dass dazu zu hören da ich haben
dafür gestern noch konkrete beispiele
gebracht es wäre auch an ihnen gewesen
entsprechende beispiele heute
vorzutragen
die habe ich aber die habe ich nicht
vernommen ich bin mit ihnen einer
meinung dass wir die intervalle strecken
könnten dass es aber auch der punkt wo
bei einer meinung sind
aber mit dieser haltung dass wir uns
hier gegenseitig kompliziert erklären
was alles in deutschland nicht
funktioniere
was aber im ausland nicht nur
funktioniert hat sondern auch gewirkt
hat womit man dort die welle brechen
konnte womit man dort auf insolvenzen
unter 30 mittlerweile gekommen ist mit
dieser debatte kommen wir nicht weiter
wir brauchen pragmatismus und keine
gegenseitige aufklären was alles nicht
funktioniert daher bitte ich dass wir
tatsächlich in dieser ausgangssperre
eine notwendige aber nicht hinreichende
maßnahme sehen
es wird allein nicht reichen aber in
keinem land in keinem land ist es
gelungen eine welle mit an der b17
mutation noch einmal in den griff zu
bekommen ohne dass man nicht auch und
nicht alleine ohne dass man nicht auch
das instrument der ausgangs
beschränkungen und nicht sperren genutzt
hätte
herr kollege lindner
bitte sehr sie können ja wieder herr
präsident der kollege lauter war
tatsächlich habe ich hier eben das
können sie im protokoll ja noch einmal
nach seine reihe von vorschlägen gemacht
sprach von masken pflicht begrenzung der
kontakte der haushalte test strategie
aufklärung auch in fremdsprachen und
beschleunigung des impfens um übrigens
zur ausgangssperre
eine solche ausgangssperre ist auch
schon von gesundheitsministern der fdp
begrüßt worden nämlich in flensburg wo
eine sozialdemokratische
oberbürgermeisterin zusammen mit unserem
fdp-gesundheitsminister bei einem
diffusen infektionsgeschehen bei noch
nicht großen fortschritt zu anfang
dieses jahres sich zu diesem instrument
genötigt sah also insofern da sind wir
nicht paniert aber so wie sie es hier in
das gesetz schreiben wollen ist es eben
unverhältnismäßig und lassen sie mich
hinzufügen denn wenn sie schon mangelnde
vollständigkeit beklagen zwar bei mir
keine absicht hätte ich mir gewünscht
dass sie wenn sie schon die wirksamkeit
der ausgangssperre gerade noch einmal
unterstrichen hätten dass sie
eingegangen wären auf die
wissenschaftliche untersuchung des
beirats der französischen regierung die
in frage gestellt haben auf einer
breiten datenbasis zwei monate ab 18 uhr
ob nicht gar eine negative wirkung von
der ausgangssperre ausgeht aufgrund der
verdichtung von kontakten der
ausgangssperren nächtliche
ausgangssperre und gab und gibt es in
deutschland in den letzten wochen und
monaten und die verwaltungsgerichte
haben diese nicht immer gekippt es kam
immer auf die begründung die
verhältnismäßigkeit an die ba budget für
die linke meine damen und herren
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben im
vergangenen jahr gegen den rat auf der
opposition die pandemie bekämpfung in
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
verlagert ein gremium was das
grundgesetz nicht kennt dieser weg hier
regt der pandemie bekämpfung ist
gescheitert die im kanzleramt
geschaffenen handlungs leitplanken haben
das land in die dritte welle manövriert
wir haben seit november einen
permanenten halb lockdown und sind immer
nach der welle es ist uns nicht gelungen
hier wirklich eine veränderung
vorzunehmen
dann kam der das bekannte oster und
desaster nach der letzten mpk ich hätte
erwartet dass sie direkt danach mit
wirkungsvollen maßnahmen der pandemie
bekämpfung in den bundestag zurückkehren
sie haben bei anne will gesagt viel zeit
haben wir nicht mehr das ist drei wochen
her passiert ist danach nichts sie sagen
das virus versteht kein zögern aber die
lage ist jetzt so dass es bereits zehn
nach zwölf ist die inzidenz steigt die
auslastung der intensivbetten steigt es
gibt dramatische appelle nahezu täglich
von dem intensivmediziner die folgen bei
jungen menschen longo wird werden immer
deutlicher sichtbar
das ist die reale situation das versagen
der verantwortlichen im umgang mit
dieser krise erscheint vielen bürgern
inzwischen als unverzeihlich meine damit
ja dazu
dazu gibt es eine chaotische
kommunikation und wir sehen doch in
anderen ländern lieber herr linder ich
muss darauf hinweisen in großbritannien
öffnen die papst in israel öffnen die
strände
ich kann ihnen sagen die diese länder
aus der pandemie gekommen sind über
millionenfache impfung und über
konsequentes handeln meine damen und
herren in den usa werden täglich vier
millionen menschen geimpft und bei uns
liegen vier millionen impfdosen rum und
gesundheitsminister hat dafür keine
reale erklärung inzwischen sind 22
prozent der amerikaner vollständig
geimpft 57 prozent der israelis 24
prozent der chilenen und bei uns der
zentrale punkt warum deutschland beim
impfen so sogar unter dem eu-schnitt
liegt ist ihrem versagen und der
bürokratie geschuldet vier monate zu
spät bestellt das sind die vier monate
die es jetzt für die bürgerinnen und
bürger besonders schwer machen meine
damen und herren das ist die reale lage
und da wo die bundesregierung in der
pflicht war haben sie es eben vielfach
nicht hinbekommen was macht eigentlich
die korona waren etwas ist denn
eigentlich damit sie gucken gerade
darauf wies mit dir steht was ist dann
mit den bundesweiten test bis heute
bestehen diese mängel vor ort und das
infektionsschutzgesetz behebt eben
keinen davon
es ist gut dass die bundesregierung auf
den weg zurück in den deutschen
bundestag ist aber es ist inakzeptabel
es ist inakzeptabel dass sie den
bundestag faktisch mit diesem gesetz
nicht stärken sondern machten und selbst
ein blankoscheck haben wollen das ist
keine stärkung des demokratischen
verfahren sondern eine abrissbirne
parlamentarismus er enthält die nach 14
monaten vor allen dingen die
ausgangssperre ein ja und zwar eine
bundesweite ausgangssperre richtig es
gibt lange ausgangssperren ist auch
möglich das ist auch völlig in ordnung
aber das ist so ist das so widersinnig
wie die äußere ruhe es ist rechtlich
höchst bedenklich ist ein
grundrechtseingriff und die aerosol
forscher die sagen natürlich eine ganz
andere position die gefahr lauert in den
innenräumen
es ist doch so dass der abendspaziergang
oder das stalking stellen sie sich mal
vor sie haben home office gehabt sie
haben homeschooling gemacht und dann
abends um 21 uhr wollen sie vielleicht
allein als alleinerziehende mutter noch
einmal für eine halbe stunde raus und
das dürfen sie nicht mit ihren besteck
kontakt beschränkungen ja aber das ist
nicht die lösung impfen das ist der
schlüssel wo ist denn der angekündigte
im fokus
wo sind dann die produktionsstätten 9 wo
ist eine nationale strategie nicht die
ministerpräsidenten sind das problem
sondern es sind die minister der cdu und
csu im bund sie haben wir schlecht
regiert deswegen ist die lage so wie sie
ist und da ist es übrigens besonders
verwerflich war sie hier so laut sind
herr brinkhaus es besonders verwerflich
dass die union das ganze land mit ihren
personalproblem belästigt es ist
verwerflich dass sie die schwersten tage
pandemie und sie reden über söder und
flaschen werden im nächsten bundestag
oppositionsführer ist lassen sie das
endlich das wäre sinnvoll das wäre
sinnvoll wenn der bund der bund war
während der gesamten pandemie nicht in
der lage für schulen luftfilter und für
lehrer rechtzeitig impfstoffe zu
beschaffen und nun soll das kanzleramt
autorisiert werden in passau oder in
rostock die schule zu schließen das ist
niemandem zu vermitteln meine damen und
herren das ist die das ist die situation
kinder
kinder sind bei ihnen nämlich der blinde
fleck lieberherr bringt aus kinder sind
bei ihnen der blinde fleck in der
pandemie bekämpfung die schulen hatten
bei ihnen nie priorität zu kindern und
familien sind sie in der pandemie
bekämpfung hammer hat aber in der
wirtschaft da sind sie wachs war ich das
ist die situation haben sie eigentlich
sorge dass die union keine spenden für
die bundestagswahl trägt sie haben wir
elf leute die wegen korruption letztlich
zurückgetreten ist fc eigene tasche das
ist doch bei der union derzeit der fall
ihnen fehlt immer noch der focus
pandemie bekämpfung bedeutet immer auch
einschränkungen privaten bei ihnen bei
den haushalten aber es geht nie darum
die wirtschaft auch mal in den fokus es
geht nicht darum die wirtschaft
anzuhalten darum geht es nicht aber es
muss darum gehen das arbeitsleben mit
sicherer zu machen und ansteckungen zu
verhindern
ein kotau vor den wirtschaftsverbänden
kontakt beschränkungen ja aber nicht so
wie sie das hier machen was wir den
schülern zumuten das muss bei
unternehmen doch gang und gäbe sein das
wäre die wahrheit frau bundeskanzlerin
die fraktion die linke kann so ihrem
gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen ich hoffe
auch veränderungen im parlamentarischen
verfahren
sie erhalten von meiner fraktion kein
blankoscheck für ihre pandemie
bekämpfung
das gesetz ist kein schnelles instrument
zum brechen der dritten welle
es ist vielfach autoritäre symbolpolitik
verbarrikadieren sie sich nicht im
kanzleramt sondern ich rate unabhängig
von dem gesetz wir brauchen endlich
einen breiten dialog ein dialog auch von
virologen und ärzten aber eben auch
pädagogen psychologen
wirtschaftswissenschaftler künstler
gewerkschaften usw
nur dann werden wir vertrauen
zurückgewinnen können das ist das
wichtigste kapitel kapital was sie haben
und das haben sie leider vielfach
missbrauch herzlichen dank
hrubesch war dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende einer der
fraktionsvorsitzende der linksfraktion
[Musik]
die bundeskanzlerin hier auf der
regierungsbank
übrigens gab es gestern meldungen das
war aber dass die bundeskanzlerin heute
eventuell an in berlin hat die 66 und
damit als über 60-jährige berechtigt zur
astra c-liga impfung das wurde
allerdings nicht bestätigt das nur am
rande jetzt katrin göring eckardt für
die grünen die fraktionsvorsitzende von
bündnis 90 die grünen bt frau
göring-eckardt herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen am beginn der
pandemie gab es so etwas wie eine
vereinbarung zwischen den bürgern und
der regierung und die gegen so die
bürgerinnen und bürger sind solidarisch
die schultern auflagen und
einschränkungen bis weit an die
schmerzgrenze und darüber hinaus zum
schutz für alle und dafür unternimmt die
regierung alles was möglich ist um
schutz zu gewährleisten und herten
abzumildern
diese verabredung ist einseitig zu
lasten der bürgerinnen und bürger
aufgekündigt hilfe kamen zu spät oder
sie kamen unzureichend stattdessen kam
im märz lockerung wider besseren wissens
und wieder besserer wissenschaft mehr
infektionen mehr schwere erkrankungen
wurden zugelassen und jetzt menschen die
auf intensivstationen liegen die zu
hause mit der krankheit kämpfen die
spätfolgen haben werden ärztinnen und
ärzte die am ende sind
ich mache mir wirklich große sorgen mit
vielen hier aber ich finde es muss eben
auch entsprechende maßnahmen geben
menschen schlagen sich gerade mit dem
letzten cent durch theaters kinos
kultureinrichtung restaurants cafés
geschäfte geschlossen seit monaten und
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht ganz
persönlich meiner seele fehlen auch
begegnungen auch zufällige resonanz live
musik aber so vielen fehlt vor allem die
aussicht und das vertrauen das ist gut
werden wird dass es funktionieren wird
dass wir uns hier wirklich gemeinsam
anstrengen
damen und herren wir sind inzwischen 80
tausend tote die wir betrauern väter
mütter großeltern freundinnen freunde
menschen die einen großen teil ihres
lebens noch vor sich hatten menschen die
uns fehlen werden ihre ideen ihre
hoffnungen ihr lachen und ihr beitrag
für das danach das gesetz dass wir heute
hier diskutieren ist nicht genug es
reicht nicht aus um die dritte welle
wirklich zu brechen es ist nicht das
alles tun frau merkel was sie hier heute
morgen gesagt hatte
und wir alle hier bis auf ein paar
notorische leutner oder quer ideologen
wissen wir müssen mehr tun um die zahlen
wirklich und dauerhaft nach unten zu
bringen
bis jetzt ist sein
infektionsschutzgesetz das nicht
ausreichend geschützt ist ist nicht
konsequent genug es kommt ja zu spät es
ist ein notbehelf und es ist nicht die
dringend benötigte strategie für die
nächsten monate mit stufenplan mit
aussicht mit klarheit was du gemacht
werden muss und wann was geöffnet werden
eine instanz von über 100 ist zu spät um
erst zu bremsen
wir müssen wir müssen konsequent zurück
auf 50 besser noch auf 35 mit
entsprechenden schritten von öffnungen
mit möglichkeiten mit testungen jahr und
natürlich mit sehr viel mehr sehr viel
konsequenter impfungen überall dort wo
es geht meine damen und herren
ja wir waren als grüne immer für eine
einheitliche transparente
nachvollziehbare bundesweite strategie
der bekämpfung der pandemie aber sie
muss eben auch wirksam sein
hier bekommen sie leider erst in der not
und das ist nicht möglich war
und das sage ich hier an die adresse mit
die afg fanatisches anderes erwartet
aber auch von herrn lindner und herr
schneider hat sich leider auch so
geäußert dass es nicht möglich war sehr
schnell
in dieser woche von mir aus in fünf
nachtsitzungen dieses gesetz zu
beschließen damit es sehr schnell
wenigstens das auf den weg gebracht
werden kann
da fehlt mir jedes verständnis
wir warten das von anderen hier auch wir
erwarten von eltern dass sie irgendwie
über nacht wieder organisieren wie es
mit der schule oder der kita wird wir
erwarten dass geschäfte sofort schließen
können und deswegen finde ich wirklich
es kommt jetzt auf jeden tag an und das
kann man nicht nur sagen da muss man
auch was tun dafür dennoch denn der
vorliegende entwurf muss dringend
nachgebessert werden eine notbremse die
wirksam ist sieht anders aus
und da geht es zuallererst für mich um
die kontakte in der arbeitswelt
die müssen maximal rechtsverbindlich
runter und der schutz muss hoch und
dafür mut dieses gesetz top kanzlei oder
öffentlicher dienst mobiles arbeiten und
home office muss pflicht sein und das
muss auch kontrolliert werden meine
damen und herren und dort aber nur dort
wo dringend vor ort gearbeitet werden
muss muss getestet werden und es muss
auch klar sein für beide seiten das
getestet werden muss auf der baustelle
muss doch auch einen helm getragen
werden und in pandemie zeiten wo es eben
getestet werden so einfach ist das in
der richtigen sein angebot aus wir
wollen ein gesetz das nicht wartet
übrigens bis die schule gänzlich in
flammen steht bevor jemand nach dem
feuerlöscher greift deshalb eine instanz
von 200 zu handeln ist zu spät das ist
kein schutz für schülerinnen und ist
somit kein schutz für sie als in meine
damen und herren für die gesundheit
unserer kinder morgens testen mindestens
zweimal die woche muss immer und ohne
incidents werte selbstverständlich seien
auch in kitas ohne tests kein
präsenzunterricht und wenn sie mich
fragen wir reden ja hier nur über die
frage der notbremse ab 100 wenn sie mich
fragen in den schulen müsste eigentlich
klar sein wechsel unterricht ab 50 wette
unterricht bei über 100 geht nur mit
sehr verbindlichen hygiene konzepten
geht nur mit es geht nur in festen
gruppen und eigentlich auch nur mit
luftfiltern meine damen und herren bitte
wir wissen dass die dass die mutation
jetzt sehr stark kinder betrifft dass
kinder ihre eltern anstecken auch das
wissen wir aus dem ausland und deswegen
sage ich zum schutz
kinder und eltern sorgen wir dafür dass
dieser schutz wirklich gewährleistet ist
und dazu gehört aber auch wenn man sehr
konsequentes in solchen fragen wir
brauchen lebensnahe regeln lieber
draußen als drinnen werden den zug an
ins außengelände der muss die oma nicht
zu hause treffen
wer hierüber ausgangssperren redet und
das scheint ja irgendwie das hauptthema
gerade zu sein der mann geklagt und was
da passiert und ich schlage wirklich
ganz klar sowas muss angemessen und muss
verhältnismäßig sein
und es ist definitiv nicht
verhältnismäßig wenn wir in der
wirtschaft weiter locker sind und die
tests nicht verbindlich sind und auf der
anderen seite die ausgangssperren machen
und nur das trage ich dies zusammen und
nur dank haben wir auch eine echte
verhältnismäßigkeit
lassen sie uns das gesetz verbessern
damit es eine echte notbremse ist meine
damen und herren und dann ist nach der
notbremse vor dem gesetz vor dem gesetz
mit einem echten stufenplan mit echter
klarheit und hören wir in der tat
darüber auch zu reden was alles nicht
geht und mit dem es nicht geht sondern
tun wir das was geht gerne gemeinsam
aber bitte auch konsequent und wirksam
vielen dank veränderungen im kalender
verfahren an diesem gesetzentwurf das
hat auch katrin göring eckardt gefordert
wie nahezu jeder redner vor ihr aber es
kommt auch auf jeden tag an hat sie
gesagt und tatsächlich dieses ganze
verfahren das wird jetzt doch nicht ganz
so schnell gehen der große koalition
sich das eigentlich gewünscht hätte denn
es gibt natürlich fristen die
eingehalten werden müssen und da f die
und fdp beispielsweise haben nicht auf
diese fristen komplett verzichtet jetzt
das nächste woche die zweite lesung der
bundesrat der schließlich auch noch
darüber befinden muss jetzt thorsten
frei für die union würde wie man sich
normalität zurück wünschen würde dann
würden wahrscheinlich viele sich die
situation von anfang letzten jahres
wünschen wir erleben das natürlich in
den gesprächen mit den bürgerinnen und
bürgern und auch an uns selber wie die
pandemie zu schaffen macht und wie die
pandemie auch müde macht und wenn man es
mit einem marathon vergleichen wollte
dann müsste man vielleicht sagen wir
sind jetzt bei kilometer 38
wo den marathonläufer die typische krise
erfasst und wo man glaubt es gibt
überhaupt kein ende mehr
obwohl in drei kilometer das licht am
ende des tunnels zu sehen ist und dieses
licht am ende des tunnels das heißt
impfen bei uns das ist es impfen wie man
sich hier hinstellen kann und sagen kann
wo ist denn der turbo wo wir vorgestern
738 1501 impfungen in deutschland hatten
dass es mir schleierhaft wir impfen und
wir legen zu und das ist das licht am
ende des tunnels aber die wahrheit ist
halt eben auch alleine zu impfen reicht
nicht da kann man den blick wenden
beispielsweise nach israel nach
großbritannien in die usa oder jetzt
auch nach chile die alle eine höhere
impfquote haben als deutschland und
voller in der dritten welle sind das
allein allein reicht nicht und deswegen
ist es unverantwortlich wenn wir jetzt
nicht die notwendigen begleitmaßnahmen
ergreifen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
fand es total interessant zum stichwort
impfen ich fand das total interessant
dass hier der fraktions vorsitzende der
sozialistischen fraktion die usa als
leuchtendes vorbild beim impfen
hinstellt wir sind diejenigen die
verantwortung nicht nur für uns selbst
übernehmen sondern auch für andere
länder
die usa tun dies nicht darüber kann man
denken wie man will aber dass die
sozialistische fraktion genau das als
leuchtendes beispiel hervorhebt das ist
ein links populismus wirklich nicht zu
überbieten
das war eine schlimme rede lieber herr
barth stieß
gehalten haben und ich werde an dieser
stelle noch etwas anderes sagt hierhin
zu stehen und von der abbruchfirma des
parlamentarismus zu sprechen wo wir hier
ein gesetz vorlegen das dem parlament so
viele möglichkeiten gibt wie nie zuvor
wir regeln als bundes unmittelbares
gesetz wir sollten dafür dass wohl
rechtsverordnungen ermöglichen dass der
bundestag diese sucht diesen zustimmen
muss mehr parlamentarismus geht doch
überhaupt nicht sagen sie doch mal wie
sich denn eigentlich gerne hätten nichts
aber auch gar nichts dazu gesagt herr
kollege frei der kollege ernst würde
hier eine zwischenfrage stellen gerne
herr kollege ernst ich dachte daher
ernst wollte eine frage stellen
doch das war dazu klaus ernst für uns
schon noch jafry gut
diese erste ich musste den sagen die
außenluft gegenwärtigen sie hier
vollzogen haben dieses gesetz ist hier
vorgelegt wird ist letztlich nichts
anderes als dass bundestag beschließen
soll dass die regierung machen konnte
diese frage was sie will
und insofern ist alles andere als eine
stärkung des parlaments hat es nichts
anderes als dass dass die regierung
einen freibrief liegt für maßnahmen die
höchst umstritten sind und auf einen
möchte ich sie mal aufmerksam machen sie
wissen ganz genau dass wir verschiedene
kontakte haben die tatsächlich zu mehr
infektionen führen wir haben die
industrie wir haben die wirtschaft da
gibt es faktisch nur beschränkungen
sie sind nicht mal in der lage in dieses
gesetz rein zu schreiben dass man doch
bitteschön testen muss der vormalige am
arbeitsplatz auffällt und bevor man sich
möglicherweise nicht so verhält dass ein
anderes ansteckt warum schreiben sie
dies nicht rein
wissen sie was ich konnte die zahl weiß
ich denn
unternehmerverbänden im winter hängen
das ist die tatsache und ich sage das
ist deshalb so schlimm
das ist deshalb so schlimm herbei weil
wir gleichzeitig wenn wir hier zum
einkaufen geht da brauche ich ihn fest
dass ich ein kaufhaus gehen konnte das
publikum rein wenn ich in den
einzelhandel gebe brauche ich im test
und comic con i 3
aber industrie wo sich täglich 40
millionen abhängig beschäftigt die
tummelt und andere anstecken können dort
drücken sie die augen zu und sagen die
sollen doch machen was sie wollen
unmöglich und jetzt habe ich sie gesetzt
insgesamt so kann man das nicht machen
kollege hans bleiben sie bestehen
so sind die regeln hier der kollege
ernst ich will die frage gerne
beantworten sie sollten vielleicht sehen
dass wir nicht nur das vierte
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz machen sondern
eine reihe von anderen gesetzen wo wir
auch regelungen im bereich des
arbeitsrechtes und des schutzes am
arbeitsplatz drin haben
der zweite teil ihrer frage wie kommen
sie eigentlich auf die idee dass wir
hier ein gesetz machen das ein freibrief
für die bundesregierung bedeutet nein
wissen sie dass die zwischenrufe von
ihnen kommen wundert mich nicht weil vor
wenigen wochen vor wenigen wochen haben
genau sie so argumentiert wie es der
herr ernst jetzt macht nur falsch bleibt
falsch falsch falsch
wir möchten gerne im bundes
infektionsschutzgesetz einen paragraphen
28b machen im absatz 1 stehen zehn
maßnahmen drin
das hat nicht die bundesregierung
entwickelt das haben die
bundestagsfraktionen der union und der
spd vorgeschlagen und stellen das hier
heute und am kommenden mittwoch zur
abstimmung es entscheidet das parlament
und im absatz 6 da steht eine
verordnungsermächtigung drin und zwar
unter dem zustimmungsvorbehalt von
bundesrat und bundestag was ist denn
daran ein freibrief für die
bundesregierung wenn sie ins gesetz
schauen dann sehen sie dass das nichts
aber auch rein gar nichts mit der
wahrheit zu tun hat was sie hier sagen
[Applaus]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das was
wir hier vorlegen das ist ein mix
unterschiedlicher maßnahmen weil wir
ganz genau wissen dass nicht eine
einzige maßnahme die wirkung erzielen
wird sondern nur die summe aus diesen
wirkung aus diesem ziel
und wenn sie jetzt hingehen und einzelne
maßnahmen herausgreifen diskreditieren
und mit gutachten kommen die ihnen
gerade in den kram passen
das hat auch die fdp gemacht das hat
auch der herr link gemacht dann ist das
einfach nicht in ordnung sondern dann
sollten sie das gesamte bild zitiert wir
haben sehr gute gutachten beispielsweise
aus kanada
da hat man untersucht die provinzen
quebec und ontario in tibet gibt es eine
ausgangs beschränkung und da hat man
festgestellt dass im vergleich zur
provinz ontario
die bewegungen zurückgegangen sind um
31% das führt dazu dass die
reproduktionsrate um 13 prozent
zurückgehen und das wiederum führt dazu
dass nicht durch die ausgangs
beschränkung alleine aber durch die
ausgangs beschränkung in einem punkt
von maßnahmen die rede produktionsquote
zurückgeht und wir damit das erreichen
dass das gesundheitssystem entlastet
wird und insel insbesondere die
intensivstationen
denn das ist doch offensichtlich dass
hat ja hier noch nicht einmal jemand
bestritten dass wir die hilferufe der
unfall und notfall und und
intensivmediziner nicht in den wind
schlagen dürfen wir haben ständig
steigende belastungen auf den
intensivstationen
der höchststand von 6.000
intensivpatienten mit cupid 19
der wird wahrscheinlich noch in diesem
monat erreicht deswegen der einzige satz
der wichtig war in der rede vom herr
bartsch war der dass er gesagt hat wir
haben zehn nach zwölf und nicht zehn vor
zwölf das ist zutreffend es ist richtig
und daraus muss man doch auch
konsequenzen ziehen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben heute
die erste lesung dieses gesetzes es ist
nur ziemlich impulsive debatte die wir
hier erleben das ist auch vollkommen in
ordnung aber ich möchte einfach dazu
aufrufen dass wir uns alle
zusammenreißen und vor dem hintergrund
dieser analyse die ja weitestgehend
geteilt wird in den nächsten tagen auch
daran arbeiten dieses gute gesetz noch
besser zu machen
und auch hier sage ich lieber bereichen
ihnen ausdrücklich die hand wir wollen
gemeinsam mit ihnen schauen wie wir
dieses gesetz noch besser und noch
effektiver machen können und natürlich
vorher in äcker gibt's da ansatzpunkte
wo man etwas tun kann sie haben das
thema der schulen angesprochen
ja das ist noch keine gute lösung die
können wir noch besser machen und auch
an der ein oder anderen stelle wird es
genauso gehen wir werden am ende
natürlich auch sehen müssen am ende
braucht jedes gesetz hier im deutschen
bundestag eine mehrheit
und wie schwierig das ist
zeigt auch die heutige debatte und im
übrigen in richtung die der
bundesratsbank gerichte diese debatte in
dieser woche und den nächsten tagen
zeigt natürlich auch dass es auch die
ministerpräsidenten in den letzten
wochen und monaten nicht leicht hatten
sondern dass es halt einfach eine
objektiv schwere aufgabe ist diese
unterschiedliche zielkonflikte
zueinander zu bringen aber das ist jetzt
unsere verantwortung und diese
verantwortung gibt uns auch unsere
verfassung das sollte meiner der stelle
nicht vergessen also okay ich dachte der
präsident ich verstehe jetzt was er
meint und deswegen komme ich zum ende
und sage hier liegt ein gutes gesetz vor
wir sollten hart daran arbeiten dass
weiter zu verbessern und dafür bitte ich
um ihre unterstützung und ihren
konstruktiven beitrag herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
der kollege spanien hatte sich zu einer
zwischenfall gemeldet aber wenn die
redezeit eines redners zu endes erteile
ich nicht mehr das wort zu
zwischenfragen jetzt hat das wort als
nächste rednerin die kollegen
druckverfahren petri frauke petry
spricht als fraktionslose abgeordnete
mittlerweile gibt es ja acht
fraktionslose hier im deutschen
bundestag und die natürlich auch
rederecht haben wenn auch eingeschränkte
zwei minuten sehr geehrter präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren es ist ein
demokratisches dilemma dass ihnen frau
bundeskanzlerin selten präzise zugehört
wird denn sie haben im ersten satz ihrer
rede
ihre motivation zur änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes glasklar
benannt wissen sie es noch es war die
letzte mpk ihre persönliche klatsche vor
den ministerpräsidenten der länder die
sie seitdem antreibt und in klar möchte
ich hinzufügen landläufig nennt man so
etwas rache für realismus und
surrealismus sind anstrengend das stimmt
schlimmer aber finde ich folgendes sie
ignorieren seit monaten
wissenschaftliche argumente für wirklich
aussagekräftige vor wut indikatoren der
pcr test war zu keinem zeitpunkt der
eigene kurve 19 seine gefährlichkeit zu
beschreiben
wir sind uns einig dass die belegung
intensivbetten dafür viel besser
geeignet ist aber dann müssten sie auch
zugeben dass in unserem ach so tollen
gesundheitssystem jahrelang die falschen
prioritäten gesetzt worden
und sie müssten strukturen sorgen dass
es ihre aufgabe als bundesregierung frau
merkel das müssen sie alles wissen die
sind promovierte physikerin vielleicht
haben sie auch schon einmal bei der
ausweitung eines pcr tests das ablesen
und fotografieren eines gels zugesehen
wollen sie den bürgern selbstständige
unternehmer in finanzwissenschaft und
ärzten und vielen anderen klugen
menschen diesen land tatsächlich
erklären dass es ihnen und die stärkung
der abwehrkräfte gegen eine krankheit
geht mit der wir ab jetzt leben müssen
nein darum geht es ihnen nicht sie
wollen nur er unqualifiziertes basta sie
sprechen damit nicht nur ein ganzes land
sondern ein
sie entfernen sie sich von ihrer eigenen
partei zunächst stehen ihnen die grünen
eher und sie schwächen ihre nachfolger
im amt
in der politik wird es häufig um ganz
andere dinge als normale bürger sehen
kann
sie wissen das aber sehr gut es ist nun
an diesem parlament meine damen und
herren ihre asymmetrischen kampf frau
merkel gegen mündige bürger und den rest
mündiger volksvertreter ein ende zu
bereiten indem diese änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes glasklar
abgeliefert frauke petry bad ist sicher
als fraktionslose abgeordnete gesprochen
hat deswegen mit etwas eingeschränkte
redezeit und als nächsten hier in dieser
aussprache erste lesung zur änderung des
diesem offiziell heißt dass
bevölkerungsschutz gesetzt aber ist im
wesentlichen eine änderung eine
ergänzung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
spricht jetzt stück wiese für die spd
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen kurt schumacher
hat einmal den satz gesagt politik
beginnt mit dem betrachten der
wirklichkeit wir können nicht die augen
davor verschließen dass wir in einer
sehr ernsten und zugespitzten situation
momentan sind wir würden uns sicherlich
eine andere lage wünschen wir würden uns
sicherlich eine andere situation
wünschen in dieser situation aber das
können wir nicht und darum ist es jetzt
erforderlich maßnahmen zu treffen
entscheidungen zu treffen und auch zu
handeln und dafür ist es erforderlich
und ich begrüße das ausdrücklich dass
wir ein bundeseinheitliches vorgehen
jetzt auf den weg bringen es ist
übrigens etwas was die spd bereits im
november gefordert hat und wo wir bisher
das gehört leider auch zur ehrlichkeit
dazu frau bundeskanzlerin nicht auf
wohlwollen in den bisherigen
verhandlungen im bundeskanzleramt
gestoßen sind aber ich begrüße diesen
schritt jetzt ausdrücklich und ich halte
ihm ehrlicherweise auch für
für uns als spd bundestagsfraktion ist
dabei eines entscheidend keine dieser
bundes verordnungen kann einfach so in
kraft treten jede dieser bundes
verordnungen die auf den weg gebracht
wird wenn wir dieses gesetz in zweiter
dritter lesung auf den weg bringen
wenn darf der zustimmung des deutschen
bundestages und ich sage ausdrücklich
für die spd-fraktion da wird es auch
keine widerspruchslösung geben es geht
nur mit der zustimmung des deutschen
bundestages dafür setzen wir uns in den
laufenden verhandlungen auch ein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich will
es auch ganz deutlich sagen dieses
gesetz ist kein misstrauensvotum gegen
die länder für mich ist es eine
optimierung des miteinanders der
föderalen ebenen wo wir zusammen da
hinkommen müssen dass wir gemeinsam
zwischen bund ländern zwischen der
kommunalen ebene zu besseren lösungen
kommen dass wir zu mehr
nachvollziehbarkeit kommen dass wir zu
mehr pragmatischem handeln letztendlich
auch kommen weil ich kann es manchmal
den bürgerinnen auch nicht erklären mein
wahlkreis der hochsauerlandkreis an der
grenze zu hessen dass in dem einen kreis
dass eine gilt und dem anderen kreis das
andere darum brauchen wir mehr
nachvollziehbarkeit einheitlichkeit das
ist auch wichtig für die akzeptanz der
bürgerinnen und bürger der krise der
kollege bild wie möglich an eine
zwischenfrage stellen die hat keinen
mehrwert vielen dank liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
auch noch mal deutlich machen warum ist
letztendlich auch wichtig ist
bundeseinheitlicher voranzugehen ich war
schon erstaunt und das muss ich wirklich
so sagen dass in dieser woche gerade
zwei ministerpräsidenten nicht den
schwerpunkt auf die kogit 19 bekämpfung
gelegt haben sondern andere situationen
versuchen momentan zu lösungen
letztendlich zu führen und ich muss auch
sagen dass es auch in einigen
bundesländern so gewesen ist das
letztendlich auch landes politisches
handeln viele fragen aufwirft ich
erinnere daran die nordrhein
westfälische schulministerin gebauer von
der fdp die für ein heilloses chaos und
durcheinander in der schulpolitik gerade
in nordrhein westfalen verantwortlich
zeit und herr lindner
ich kann die kritik an den ausgangs
beschränkungen auch die rechtlichen
argumente nachvollziehen das ist eine
debatte die gerade geführt wird was
allerdings zur ehrlichkeit in der
debatte dazu gehört und das haben sie
verschwiegen dass in der korona schutz
verordnung des landes
nordrhein-westfalen ausgangs
beschränkungen zulässig sind und einige
kreise in nordrhein westfalen mit ihrer
zustimmung in düsseldorf das auch schon
möglich machen und das verschweigen sie
hier und ich habe vor ihm kein
kritisches wort gegenüber den
anordnungen der nordrhein westfälischen
landesregierung gehört und das gehört
zur ehrlichkeit dazu
für unser spd ist es jetzt wichtig bei
den ausgangs beschränkungen zwischen 9
und 5 uhr den individualsport möglich zu
machen wenn jemand von der arbeit kommt
und er hat einen langen tag gehabt dann
muss er die möglichkeit haben joggen zu
gehen spazieren zu gehen draußen
unterwegs zu sein
hier werden wir uns in den beratungen
noch mal dafür einsetzen ich halte das
für sehr richtig und auch für vollkommen
nachvollziehbar und wir müssen auch noch
mal dahin schauen dass es nicht um den
incidents wert 100 einen jojo effekt
gibt zwischen öffnen und schließen dass
wir hier doch zu einem mehr an
rechtssicherheit kommen ich glaube das
ist wichtig ansonsten impfen weiter
voranbringen mehr testen klare
perspektive für die bürgerinnen
bürger dafür setzen wir uns als spd in
vielen dank und der krise hat für die
spd fraktion zumindest auch noch mal
klar gemacht du hast diesen zweiten
punkt anbelangt da zug vielleicht gleich
nochmal ist doch nochmal carsten hilfe
für die afg fraktion als
kurzinterventionen leider haben sich
inzwischen frage nicht zugelassen ihre
begründung das miteinander reden keinen
mehrwert hätte das lässt tief blicken ob
ihre demokratische einstellung
ich möchte ihnen ein zitat vorlesen wer
einmal mit dem notstand spielen sollte
um die freiheit einzuschränken wird
meine freunde und mich auf den
barrikaden zur verteidigung der
demokratie finden und dies ist ganz
wörtlich gemeint dieses zitat habe ich
bei mir im büro hängen und sie wissen
sicherlich von wem dieses zitat ist es
von willy brandt und herr willy brandt
würde sich wahrscheinlich jetzt im grabe
umdrehen wie die spd die demokratie
die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung hier zu grabe trägt sie
geben dieser bundesregierung die
ermächtigung die des förderalismus
prinzip auszuhebeln und die
gewaltenteilung auszuhebeln
bitte ich würde gerne wissen ob sie sich
dann wenn die demokratie angegriffen
wird auch sowie das er willy brandt
machen würde auf den barrikaden zur
verteidigung der demokratie finden werde
[Musik]
er könnte wie sie mögen sie antworten
dann haben sie das wort
sehr geehrter herr hilfe an wurde gerne
auch ihre ihre ausführung die sie gerade
getätigt haben ich will ihnen aber ganz
deutlich sagen wer wie sie nicht mit
beiden beinen auf dem boden des
grundgesetzes steht wer wie sie gegen
die freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung agitiert von dem brauch
sich die spd-bundestagsfraktion keine
ratschläge letztendlich geben zu lassen
und ich kann ihnen nur sagen
der einzigste grund warum willy brandt
sich im grabe umdrehen würde bei ihrer
intervention die sie gerade abgegeben
haben so jetzt also noch mal gerade was
dirk wiese in seiner rede angesprochen
hatte das ist nämlich ein punkt der in
der öffentlichkeit noch nicht ganz so
viel beachtung findet für die bundesrat
bleiben sie das ist ja der eine punkte
ergänzt wird der andere punkt ist
tatsächlich dass der bund künftig
verordnungen machen kann
zu den maßnahmen was sonst sache der
länder ist und der bundestag kann im
moment zumindest wie es im gesetzentwurf
steht innerhalb von sieben tagen
widersprechen muss also nicht zustimmen
aber da wird man vielleicht im
gesetzgebungsverfahren auch noch mal
trank gehen intensivbetten ca 4700
patienten sind in intensivmedizinischer
behandlung vor einem monat war es knapp
die hälfte und die hilferufe der
intensivmediziner sind nicht zu
überhören sie raten uns zu starken
maßnahmen sie raten uns mehr maßnahmen
zu ergreifen die dynamik ist ungebrochen
und insbesondere die lage in den
krankenhäusern spitzt sich zum teil
dramatisch zu wir sind nicht bereit die
warnungen der mediziner zu ignorieren
die mediziner und pflegekräfte sind es
die im notfall helfen und leben retten
wenn wir vom gesundheitssystem reden
dass wir sichere und schützen wollen ja
dann meinen wir sicherlich auch die
betten
wir meinen die geräte aber im besonderen
main in besonderem maße meinen wir das
personal die mediziner und pflegekräfte
sind sie sind das höchste gut das wir
haben sie sind gesicht hand und herz
dieses gesundheitssystem und deswegen
müssen wir sie schützen und genau das
tun wir jetzt mit diesem gesetz wir
müssen handeln und zwar wir müssen die
kontakte reduzieren wir müssen die
infektionsketten unterbrechen und
gleichzeitig für impfen wir was geht in
der aus der impfdosen kommt die
befreiung aus dieser pandemie heraus
impfen ist der weg und genau das tun wir
auch mit wachsenden erfolg in diesen
bereichen
jetzt sind drei bereiche zentral das ist
zum einen das private umfeld das
arbeitsleben und natürlich schule und
kita
diese drei bereiche haben eine zentrale
rolle für das infektionsgeschehen wir
müssen kontakte spürbar reduzieren
gerade im privaten bereich dazu nutzt
auch die ausgangssperre sie ist ein
wichtiges instrument für die
beschränkung von sozialkontakten und das
bestätigen übrigen auch eine vielzahl
von studien auch internationaler art und
deswegen gehen wir auch diesen weg die
ausgangs beschränkungen sind richtig und
für das arbeitsleben haben wir bereits
den rahmen gesetzt mit der
arbeitsstättenverordnung home office
überall dort wo möglich und dort wo
große präsenz zwingend notwendig ist da
geld abstand da geht maske und jetzt
auch entsprechend dieses verpflichtende
testangebot durch die arbeitgeber
denn wir wollen infektionen möglichst
schnell erkennen und infektionsketten
unterbrochen unterbrechen
auch die schulen sind teil des
infektionsgeschehen kollege
starke texte zwischen freiheit der
kollege dr
selbstverständlich geht den erlös frage
der linksfraktion fragen zu lassen ich
habe mich an der stelle gemeldet als sie
auf das arbeitsleben zu sprechen kam
wir haben ja hier häufig die diskussion
über systemrelevant und nicht
systemrelevant sind sie nicht mit mir
der auffassung dass wir in überlegungen
entwickeln sollten und nicht nur
überlegungen sondern auch beschlüsse
fassen nicht systemrelevante produktion
stillzulegen für eine bestimmte zeit und
wenn sie mit mir da einer meinung sind
können sie mir sagen was sie unter nicht
systemrelevant verstehen würden eine
sehr verehrte frau kollegin also wir
müssen auch in dieser pandemie darauf
achten dass wir wirtschaften auch
ermöglichen da wo es geht
das hängt auch damit zusammen dass wir
arbeitsplätze sichern wollen und
deswegen reden wir nicht über stilllegen
von entsprechenden wirtschaftszweigen
ganz im gegenteil
sondern wir reden darum arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und da kommen wir auch mit
unseren corona hilfen zum zuge und das
tun wir in diesem bereich und
gleichzeitig schauen wir darauf dass wir
im rahmen der arbeitsstättenverordnung
darauf achten dass das
infektionsgeschehen gerade auch im
betrieb beherrschbar bleibt und ich
erfahre gerade aus den unternehmen
heraus eine sehr hohe eigenmotivation
denn die wenigsten wollen doch
tatsächlich infektionen im betrieb haben
weiß ich dass auf den betriebsablauf und
den erfolg letztendlich auswirkt und das
ist der weg den wir in diesem bereich
gehen meine sehr verehrten darunter die
schulen sind teil des
infektionsgeschehen wir wollen schule
aber auch in der schule braucht es klare
schutzkonzepte deshalb setzen wir beim
präsenzunterricht auf die testpflicht
zweimal in der woche und wird der
schwellenwert von 200 bei der sieben
tage incidents überschritten so sieht es
der gesetzentwurf vor
der präsenzunterricht an den schulen
eingestellt
angesichts dieses dynamischen
infektionsgeschehen dass wir derzeit
verzeichnen ist die schwelle von 200
viel zu hoch in hessen runter in diesem
bereich richtung 100 das halte ich in
diesem bereich für richtig herr kollege
trage der kollege kleinwächter würde
noch gerne zwischenfrage stellen möchte
werter herr kollege stracke vielen dank
dass sie die zwischenfrage zu lassen und
ich stelle sie an sie weil sie ja jurist
sind und sie haben gerade viele
ausgeführt dass jahres
infektionsgeschehen eindämmen wollen und
ähnliche dinge das glaube ich ihnen
sogar ich gehe davon aus dass ihn das
leben und die körperliche unversehrtheit
der menschen durch aus dem herzen liegt
aber ich habe eine frage an sie warum
fügen sie dann in das gesetz das sie
heute in der ersten lesung haben und in
der zweiten dritten lesung ja nächste
woche verabschiedet werden soll ein dass
die grundrechte der körperlichen
unversehrtheit artikel 2 absatz 2 satz 1
des grundgesetzes
neben weiteren grundrechten
eingeschränkt und auch durch
rechtsverordnungen nach absatz 6 das ist
das was dann unserer bundeskanzlerin
frau dr angela merkel zu gute kommen
soll weiter eingeschränkt werden sollen
also was ist dir sehen dass sie explizit
festlegen dass das grundrecht auf
körperliche unversehrtheit eingeschränkt
wird wenn sie eigentlich und das kann ja
die einzige grund rechtliche begründung
überhaupt für ihre ganzen
infektionsschutz maßnahmen seien das
grundrecht auf körperliche
unverletzlichkeit und verletzlichkeit
irgendwie verstärken wollen können sie
mir das bitte juristisch mal aufdröseln
warum sie ausgerechnet die grundrechte
der körperlichen unversehrtheit
einschränken wollen das ist ein
abwehrrecht der menschen gegenüber dem
staat dass ihnen nichts getan
warum soll das hier und heute
eingeschränkt werden wer der
kleinwächter mit dieser gesetzesentwurf
wollen wir kontakte reduzieren und das
geht natürlich nur durch gewisse schutz
maßnahmen die wir ergreifen und im
rahmen dieses gesetzesentwurf ist auch
formuliert haben
und natürlich gehört ist da dazu dass
wir auch im rahmen des zitiergebot es
die dinge auch aufgreifen
da wo unter umständen eingegriffen wird
das ist ganz normal in diesen bereichen
und im rahmen der rechtsverordnung die
wir ergreifen wollen haben wir die idee
zu sehen wie wirkt sich dann
beispielsweise das ins geschehen wir
wirken sich testungen aus und müssen wir
dann vor diesem hintergrund dass gelten
der jetzt zu verabschieden der recht
unter umständen entsprechenden anpassen
das geht nur gemeinsam mit dem deutschen
bundestag das geht nur gemeinsam mit dem
bundesrat also nichts was in dieser zeit
irgendwie gefährdend für die menschen
ist das ist nicht das ziel
ganz im gegenteil wir wollen schützen
wir wollen das leben schützen wir wollen
retten in dem bereich und das ist das
ziel das wir uns von dem wir uns
gemeinsam versammelt es wäre schön wenn
sie da auch als afd mal mitmachen würden
in diesem bereich aber das tun sie nicht
bei ihnen die menschen egal sind und das
lassen wir ihnen nicht durchgehen
meine sehr verehrten damen mit diesem
gesetz gelten für alle städte und
landkreise die eine 7 tage incidents von
über 100 aufweisen gleichen regeln unter
100 bleiben die länder zuständig und
verantwortlich wir haben erneut eine
schwere zeit vor uns genau für diese
zeit gilt nun das vorliegende gesetz und
danach kommen die notwendigen schritte
ich bitte ihn begleiten sie dieses
gesetzesvorhaben konstruktiv es ist
zentral für unsere gemeinschaft
herzliches dankeschön
stephan stracke war das der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der cdu csu fraktion und wir hatten eben
schon das rederecht für fraktionslose
abgeordnete hier im deutschen bundestag
acht stück gibt es mittlerweile an der
zahl
frauke petry hat schon gesprochen wir
jetzt ein weiterer fraktionslose
abgeordnete marius mieruch ebenfalls mit
zwei minuten redezeit sehr geehrter herr
präsident meine damen und herren zum
vierten mal verlangt diese
bundesregierung vom parlament die
einschränkung von grundrechten die
kompetenzverschiebung richtung exekutive
und die and plums ente regierung dieser
republik mit keinem wort hat frau merkel
heute morgen deutlich gemacht warum der
bund das was die länder schon machen
besser kann und warum dieses gesetz
überhaupt erforderlich ist
was der wissenschaftliche dienst des
bundestages schon letztes jahr als
verfassungsrechtlich fragwürdig
bewertete wird nun im vierten aufguss
zum verfassungsbruch
die unverletzlichkeit der wohnung längst
vergangenheit demonstrationsrecht massiv
eingeschränkt bewegungsfreiheit wird zur
farce
nichts hat diese regierung in der
pandemie vernünftig geregelt bekommen
und jetzt mast die sich an die
hinterletzte klaiber ostfriesischen
strand oder im bayerischen wald
regulieren zu wollen
sie brauchen uns das impfpflaster ein
wälzten die testpflicht auch noch mit
beta test vielleicht auch noch das
eigene versagen auf die unternehmen ab
deren hilfe sie nicht rechtzeitig
auszahlen und als gipfel der
unverschämtheit behauptet diese
bundesregierung auch noch eine solche
gesetzesvorlage bräuchte nicht mal die
absegnung durch den bundesrat
und es sei keine zeit für lange
wissenschaftliche debatten und jetzt
muss alles innerhalb von einer woche
durchgepeitscht werden nein sie hatten
14 monate zeit eine solche verachtung
parlamentarische verfahren ist wirklich
der absolute gipfel in der laufenden
legislatur der bundestag wird zum reinen
abnickverein degradiert der ihn einen
freifahrtschein für bundesweite
notstands verordnung geben soll
denn so sinnvoll bundeseinheitliche
regelung auch sein
dieses gesetz schafft weit mehr und
andere fakten die für die bürger aktuell
noch gar nicht kalkulierbar sind
das parlament bleibt befehlsempfänger
während von ihrer seite weder
kurskorrekturen noch
verantwortungsübernahme kamen die größe
eines rücktrittes hat hier schon längst
keiner mehr wären irgendwo im land 4
millionen impfdosen rumliegen wo keiner
weiß wo die eigentlich hingehören
wir werden corona nicht besiegen indem
wir den deutschen föderalismus und die
grundlagen unserer parlamentarischen
demokratie zerstören
echte demokraten zeigen eine regierung
mit solchen vorhaben eine klare rote
karte vielen dank
voraussichtlich letzte dieser debatte
ist der kollege johannes fechner es
bedient und er ist der rechtspolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
zuhörerinnen und zuhörer die lage ist
unbestritten dramatisch wir hatten in
den letzten tagen immer über 200 tote
pro tag und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
handeln
ein ausdrückliches dankeschön auch von
mir in dieser stelle an alle
pflegekräfte die sich aufopferungsvoll
um alle erkrankten kümmern ganz
herzliches dankeschön hierfür und dass
sich die lage zuspitzt das hängt auch
damit zusammen dass die beschlüsse der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz nicht
umgesetzt worden und deswegen ist es
nötig dass wir hier heute vom bund
verbindliche vorgaben für die länder
machen diese bundes notbremse ist
notwendig ich will nicht verheimlichen
dass es wenn es nach uns gegangen wäre
wir dieses projekt schon im november auf
der tagesordnung gehabt haben
das wollten die kollegen von der union
damals nicht aber besser nie als spät
jedenfalls ist es eine ganz wichtige
maßnahme dass wir hier einheitliche zu
einheitlichen maßnahmen hier heute
kommen nach der notbremse
die wir hier heute haben alle vorliegen
haben werden die länder keinen spielraum
mehr haben für diese maßnahmen und man
kann sich darüber streiten ob diese
maßnahmen die wir hier vor sehen
überhaupt ausreichen werden um die
dritte welle zu brechen oder ob nicht
weitere maßnahmen erforderlich sind aber
eins ist auch klar wir können nicht
zuschauen wie die zahlen insbesondere
die todeszahlen hier weiter ansteigen
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir
hierfür mehr bundeseinheitlich kite
sorgen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das gilt insbesondere für die tests
pflichten das ist aus meiner sicht eines
der wichtigsten elemente hier dank an
hubertus heil für die guten vorschläge
es ist sinnvoll dass wir die
schülerinnen und schüler testen und auch
dass wir die unternehmen verpflichten
ihren mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern
hier ein testangebot zu machen eine ganz
wichtige maßnahme aber liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es wäre gift wenn solche
maßnahmen das gilt für alle corona
maßnahmen von gerichten gekippt werden
das stört massiv das schädigt das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger und
deswegen müssen wir auch in der pandemie
ganz genau auf die verhältnismäßigkeit
und die angemessenheit der maßnahmen
achten und damit komme ich zum thema
ausgangssperren ich finde
ausgangssperren sind grundsätzlich ein
geeignetes mittel um dafür gibt den
wunsch einer zwischenfrage hälfte
debatte hat ein großes ego das will ich
wieder nicht gefährden
wir haben
die ausgangssperren sind grundsätzlich
geeignet um die kontakte einzuschränken
deshalb sind sie sinnvoll aber ganz klar
will ich auch hier erwähnen
ich finde es gut ist die hamburger zum
beispiel gemacht haben dass es möglich
ist dass man abends noch spazieren gehen
kann mit der partnerin oder dem partner
dass man im freien sport machen kann
auch abends nach feierabend und deswegen
ist für die spd fraktion auf jeden fall
dieses thema in den beratungen gesetzt
ich finde wir sollten hier und zwar so
dass die länder nicht wie davon
abweichen können eine möglichkeit
schaffen dass diese ausnahme im gesetz
steht liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und
auch ganz klar dass der bundestag bei
allen wesentlichen entscheidungen das
letzte wort haben muss das gilt
insbesondere für diese regelung hier
dass die bundesregierung per
rechtsverordnung zu weiteren maßnahmen
besucht werden soll da muss der
bundestag darüber entscheiden
insbesondere wenn es um die frage geht
wie gehen wir eigentlich mit geimpften
und den genesenen um das ist eine so
wesentliche entscheidung das muss hier
der bundestag entscheiden gehen wir also
in diese beratungen von göring eckardt
hier sind flott heute mittag die
sachverständigenanhörung montag die
sondersitzung der ausschüsse und am
mittwoch der abschluss also wir sind ja
sehr flott unterwegs der lage angemessen
vielen dank
johannes fechner war das der
rechtspolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion hier als der letzte redner
in dieser aussprache erste weesow und er
hat es schon angesprochen jetzt geht's
los mit dem parlamentarischen verfahren
also bzw
es geht weiter in den ausschüssen
natürlich heute mittag die
expertenanhörung im gesundheitsausschuss
dann am montag die befassung die
ordentliche befassung der mit beratenden
ausschüsse dann mit der
beschlussempfehlung und damit wird ein
zweiter dritte lesung der bundesrat muss
dann darüber noch befinden auch wenn es
momentan als einspruchsgesetz behandelt
wird aber der bundesrat muss ist
trotzdem billigen das wird
wahrscheinlich am donnerstag der fall
sein dann muss der bundespräsident das
gesetz aber noch unterschreiben und es
muss im bundesgesetzblatt veröffentlicht
werden und dann müsste beispielsweise
weil die 100er instanz ja sozusagen an
drei tage frist gebunden ist dann wenn
es im bundesgesetzblatt steht eben erst
noch diese drei tage über 100 in
jeweiligen landkreisen
angesehen werden bevor dann automatisch
diese bundeseinheitliche corona bremse
in kraft tritt wo eben die inzidenz
solange über 100 liegt also das wird
schon noch eine zeit dauern
die kanzlerin hat gesagt wer wie wer
sind wir denn wenn wir diese notrufe
über hören und sie meinte natürlich die
mit intensivmediziner und jetzt haben
allerdings schon einige bundesländer
angekündigt denn die möglichkeit zu
einer notbremse die gibt es ja bereits
das ist angesprochen worden
als bund länder beschloss und
mecklenburg vorpommern baden württemberg
beispielsweise haben angekündigt wir
warten nicht auf die bundeseinheitliche
notbremse wir machen das schon vorher
denn die länder habe dazu die
möglichkeit so